c'est toujours une excellente nouvelle
d'avoir plein de nouveaux smartphones a
testé et la journée les trois ans emma 3
dans les masses ans le nouveau
smartphone de au pot on a le au port et
nos quatre qui étaient présentés il ya
pas très longtemps il ya le regno quatre
aides
et puis aujourd'hui à ce pacte celui là
c'est le reno kad pro alors vous le
savez je sais que vous le savez pas ce
que c'est marqué dans le digne de la
vidéo vous avez cliqué vous êtes au
courant vous êtes des malins bravo et
bien le cas le profil et là j'ai déjà
testé depuis quelques temps je lis avec
moi je m'amuse bien et les rênes aux
quatre pros il est très intéressant et
surtout bien très gros focus marketing
été fait par pau dessus sur trois points
le premier point c'est la 5g parce que
oui bien évidemment on est sur un
smartphone 5g s'écrit ici comme le port
salut je peux si vous voyez bien voilà 5
g et on a de la 5g ça c'est très très
cool aujourd'hui la 5g n'est pas encore
arrivé en france donc pour tester la
simple décence au smart phone c'est
compliqué il y là de la 5g
mais je ne peux pas être testé à 5 g ca
ses premiers points deuxième point qui
était mis en avant propos et bien c'est
le fait d'avoir de la charge très rapide
ces deux-là superbook 2.0 et avec cette
superbe look 2.0 on a un bloc de charge
de 65 watts qui permet de recharger
extrêmement rapidement et ça c'est très
très cool
et le troisième point est bien c'est un
gros focus café au pot sur ce smartphone
sur de la vidéo parce que oui c'est un
smartphone qui est dédié à la vidéo pour
tous ceux qui veulent filmer que ce soit
avec lé caméra arrière la caméra avant
avec une super stabilisation on l'a donc
ces trois belles promesses faites propos
on va regarder si la marque les tiens et
surtout on va regarder ce que nous
propose ce nouveau smartphone dopo à
savoir le réno quatre pros c'est
aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est réalisé en
partenariat avec toupet go alors poulpe
et où je ne sais pas si vous connaissez
j'en ai déjà parlé il ya pas très
longtemps sur youtube mais également sur
instagram poulpeo c'est un système de
cashback qui vous permet de récupérer de
l'argent sur les achats que vous faites
le cash back pour vous expliquer c'est
très simple vous allez sur internet sur
votre site préféré vous faites des
achats en ligne et vous récupérez une
partie de la somme de quelle manière ça
fonctionne c'est très simple vous allez
sur le site de poulpeo ou sans leurs
applications parce que oui poulpeo c'est
également une application sur ios mais
également sur android
je vous montre le fonctionnement sur mon
application poulpeo je vais avoir accès
à tous mais cache bag et la rouge
retrouve les best of cash back alors y
en a énormément je peux venir chercher
également par catégorie joué par exemple
que sur la blanche porte j'ai 7%
achat qui me seront remboursés sur
picwic tonnes est perdu on est bientôt
en période de noël 8% rembourser je vais
aller sur un plein de sites divers et
variés cdiscount 3% boulanger 1,6 pour
cent par exemple pickwick tog allez on
vous dit que c'est bientôt noël
je vais cliquez sur activer le cash back
je vois comme un manche et un cash back
à 3%
et là il est monté à 8% donc en profiter
je clique sur activer le cashback sa
activement cashback donc maintenant tous
les achats de places assises pickton
faut bien penser à l'acte iv avant je
n'ai plus qu'à femmes au shopping et je
récupère et 8% en cash back directement
dans mon compte poulpeo c'est vraiment
cool et en plus de ça dès que j'aurai 10
euros dans la cagnotte pour demander un
virement pour récupérer mon argent c'est
un système gratuit pratique autant vous
dire que je vous invite à venir le
découvrir vous aimez les liens en bas
dans la description pour vous inscrire
et d'ailleurs très bientôt je veux
donner les résultats du jeu concours je
ne sais pas si vous avez suivi
eh bien on en trouve à récupérer 100
euros en carte d'achat à dépenser dans
l'un des sites partenaires c'est très
facile d'ailleurs plus encore vous
participez extrêmement rapidement il
suffit de vous inscrire sur le site de
poulpeo via le site ou via l'application
vous cliquer sur je suis paris n'est
vous rentrez le code greu 2020 premiers
bénéfices vous allez récupérer non pas 3
euros ferme et 5 euros offerts sur votre
inscription et en plus dès que vous
aurez fait votre premier achat en cash
back et bien vous serez automatiquement
sélectionnée pour participer au tirage
au sort et ça c'est une super nouvelle
je vous annonce le résultat la semaine
prochaine sur instagram utilisée sans
risque pour faire des économies que ce
soit pendant le black friday la salle
berwick ou bien encore noël
je vous ai mis les liens en bas d'un
description et réflexes poulpeo comme ça
vous allez économiser l'argent en
faisant vos achats mais avant de rentrer
dans le vif du sujet je vous invite à
venir vous abonner au camp sur le petit
bouton rouge que vous avez juste là pour
tout savoir sur la cuvette les
téléphones les montrent les tablettes
les ordinateurs on en tête y en a plein
de tous les côtés ça c'est très très
cool dont je vous invite à cliquer sur
le bouton en dessous à actionner la
cloche comme ça vous serez notifié dès
qu une prochaine vidéo arrivera et ça
c'est très bien regardez-moi ça comme
c'est tout mignon j'aime beaucoup le
travail de oppose le dis je le redis une
fois de plus opposé une marque que
j'aime beaucoup
déjà parce que les équipes sont très
cools bisous à vous tous je vous aime
mais surtout parce qu'ils font des
smartphones qui sont vraiment de très
très très très bonne facture et il faut
de plus avec cette gamme raynaud 4 au
pot n'a pas du tout démérité
déjà on est un smartphone qui est
extrêmement une prise en main qui est
vraiment hyper hyper agréable alors il
un petit peu long on va avoir en termes
de protection un verre corning gorilla
glass 5 à l'avant mais également à
l'arrière vous le voyez on a un écran
qui est incurvé on a ce petit but là ce
petit trou dans laquelle qui vient loger
est la caméra de celle ci ça
fonctionnera ici un petit bouton pour
venir l'allumé pour l'éteindre avec une
petite empreinte verte qui est très très
très cool un haut parleur micro de
l'usbc pour venir le recharger votre
tiroir de cartes sync est là pour mettre
une double sim mais pas du tout
l'extension de cartes mémoire je vous
l'expliquais dans quelques instants
vos boutons pour le volume votre micro
pour la réduction de bruit triple module
photo avec un laser qui est planqué là
le flash
moi j'aime bien le dos je trouve
vraiment très très très sympa d'un
touché matt pas de traces de doigts
hormis ce petit module photo mais bon
faut vraiment venir chercher 172 g c'est
quand même extrêmement léger on a un
cadre qui est en alliage d'aluminium on
a un petit capteur d'empreintes
digitales qui va déverrouiller
extrêmement rapide on est con
effectivement si votre visage par des
hommes derrière la caméra il m'a vu je
déverrouille ces pratiques comme je le
disais on a un écran incurvé c'est un
écran amoled de 6,5 pouces résolution
full hd plus de 1400 parmi 84 cents de
pixels par pouce ratio vingt neuvième un
écran qui occupent 80 13,4 pour cent de
la face avant une gamme de couleurs 100%
des slips et 3 ou alors srgb moi je
trouve vraiment très très lumineux
indique le pousser encore plus fort la
en écran certifié lutter contre les
lumières bleues h dernis puissant alors
ici on a un truc est vraiment
intéressant c'est qu'on a un taux de
rafraîchissement de 90 ans alors je fais
une petite révision si vous si ça vaut
pas pas forcément ou si vous n'êtes pas
au courant si vous le savez vous allez
voir c'est très simple en fait le 80
dire c'est quoi c'est le nombre d'image
que vous allez avoir par seconde
plus vous en avez et plus le contenu est
fluide petit bémol c'est ça va venir
consommer davantage de batteries donc là
vous avez un switch intelligente entre
du 60 m un peu plus usuels classique sur
les smartphones et du 90 hertz
vous aurez donc du 90e uniquement
lorsque vous avez des applications qui
pourront afficher du 90e
vous avez un processeur fait pour le
gaming c'est le stand dragonne 7 165 g g
pour remy voilà vous place à total comme
ça vous le savez et on a une fréquence
d'échantillonnage de 180 hertz un
smartphone qui coûte 799 euros
alors pour 799 euros on aurait pu et
éventuellement espérer avoir un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 hertz ou 244
hertz existe également pour moi 90 on a
très très bien la faire ici au pot n'a
pas délaissé la partie audio bien
contraire nous ont proposé un combo très
intéressant ce café au port là dessus
c'est de vous proposer des haut parleurs
stéréo un premier haut parleurs qui se
situe juste là il ya un deuxième haut
parleurs qui situe ici en façade alors
vous me direz rien de bien bien
déconnant c'est vrai néanmoins vous avez
quand même un son dolby atmos il vous
suffit d'aller dans vos paramètres dans
son et notifications sont globales dolby
atmos et là vous allez pouvoir choisir
en train sont intelligents théâtre jeux
musique
à vous de voir correspond le mieux à vos
oreilles en tout cas vous avez choix
assez pratique et en plus de ça la
qualité audio est plutôt bonne
nos canaux sont qui est assez grave au
spectre qui est assez large alors une
fois de plus on reste sur un smartphone
donc on va pas s'attendre à voir un truc
un peu magique mais c'est plutôt bien
est ce que vient vraiment faire ce haut
parleur l'a même si c'est pas parfait au
niveau de l'image stéréoscopique c'est
élargir le son et apporter quelque chose
en plus sur le côté parce que ce qui
aurait été vraiment bien c'est qu'on ait
le même haut parleur que celui là
positionné ici on aurait une vraie belle
image stéréoscopique et sortait beaucoup
plus immersif
sauf que là c'est pas le cas et c'est
souvent le cas comme ça dans plusieurs
smartphones mais ça ne s'arrête pas là
puisque vous avez du bluetooth 5.1 un
grand standard une fois de plus
ici pas de prise jack par contre 1 mais
côté codec pour votre bluetooth cinq
points vous avez de la péter x a pété x
hd ap txt wsl des ac a assez et sbc la
partie performance est aussi très bonne
il y en bien complètement dingos là
dessus on retrouve comme je le disais un
snapdragon
765 gg guémy on a ici 12 giga de ram la
techno c'est la lpddr2 4x c'est pas de
la techno drame mais ça fonctionnera
très bien et ici on à 256 go de stockage
en ef s 2.1 non extensible alors moi ou
ça bien sur le papier ça me plaît ça me
séduit maintenant j'ai un petit bémol à
apporter c'est à dire qu'on est sur un
smartphone qui coûtent quasiment 800
euros et si vous regardez à la
concurrence dans cette gamme de prix là
et notamment du côté de shiwan pl us
alors attention pas pas forcément
toujours de la même chose les techno
propriétaire au pot que vous ne pouvez
pas chez one place mais juste pour
situer par rapport aux prix eh bien vous
trouverez ce qui se fait de mieux en
termes de processeurs ans un dragon 865
vous retrouverez en techno drame de la
lpddr2 5
ici on a une fiche technique qui est
solide qui marche bien mais
vu positionnement tarifaire et bien on
peut trouver mieux pour un peu moins
chère juste sur la partie performance
c'est une question à se poser savoir
maintenant qu'est ce qui est réellement
important pour vous alors rassurez vous
voulez jouer fortnight s'étonnera très
bien vous n'aurez pas de ralentissement
peut-être un petit peu de chauffe au
niveau de votre smartphone mais rien de
très grave là dessus s'est joué à
plusieurs jeux il marche il marche bien
pour les trois quarts des usages voire
même 90% des usages
ça fera parfaitement l'affairé regarde
et surtout tous n'arrivent en 53e
position est que ce corps de 325 1187 en
dessous du red mica 35 g en dessous du
samsung galaxy note 10 et au dessus du
midi slight et du samsung galaxy s 9
plus mais ce qui fait la réelle force de
ce smartphone et c'est une des promesses
que nous a faits au pot sur son reno kad
procès ça tchatche très rapide c'est la
superbe look 2.0 alors la superbe look
2.0 elle est vraiment intéressante parce
que en fait vous n'avez pas une batterie
vous avez deux batteries vous avez deux
batteries de 2000 milliampères chaque
usq de la l'équivalent de 4000
milliampères mais surtout ses deux
batteries ce qui est super c'est
qu'elles vont venir se rechargent écoute
en même temps ça nous permet de la
recharge est beaucoup plus vite et
notamment grâce à ce boom de charge 65
watts ce qui fait que au lieu d'avoir
une seule grosse batterie 4000 milliards
terreur vous allez branché et recharger
vous avez deux batteries que vous aller
recharger en même temps ça ira plus vite
tout est vraiment utiliser et c'est là
où au pot extrêmement fort avec cette
techno de charge
la superbe look 2.0 ça vous permet de
recharger de 0 à 60 % en 15 minutes et
de 0 à 100% en 36 minutes autant vous
dire que ça va très très vite
et qu'est ce que ça nous apporte sa com
bénéfices et bien tout simplement le
fait de vous dire que vous n'allez plus
vous posez la question du as que j'ai
assez batterie est ce qu'il me manque
vous vous levez vous n'avez plus
beaucoup de batterie vous le branchez
vous prenez une douche vous sortez vous
êtes tranquille pour la journée vous
avez une autonomie d'une journée a
minima sans problème une journée me voir
deux jours si vous êtes vraiment
tranquille mais surtout l'idée de cette
techno c'est que ça vous libère l'esprit
vous ne vous posez plus la question de
la masse il fonde le charger pas le
temps comment je vais faire vous avez
une petite prise cinq minutes 10 minutes
vous êtes reparti il vous est peinard et
ça c'est extrêmement rassurant mais ce
smartphone dispose d'un autre avantage
et non des moindres c'est toute la
partie logicielle tous tourné si sur un
android
vous trouvez color os 7 points 2 écolo
est ce c'est très cool c'est assez clair
lisible et moyens des petits parma qui
sont tout bête mais qui sont vraiment
extrêmement pratique batterie par
exemple vous pouvez activer le mode
super économies d'énergie qui vous
emmène jusqu'à deux jours 5 heures et 39
minutes
y a plus grand chose qui tourne vous
avez leur vous pouvez appeler envoyer
des messages vous avez 6 appli préféré
prévenir actionner on a d'autres modes
qui sont intéressants comme le au port
il axe pour venir vous relaxer et
trouver la paix intérieure
on peut aller très très très loin la
rame en jeu sur 20 mais un des points
forts chez au pot c'est aussi la photo
alors la photo si c'est pas forcément ce
qui est mis en avant en terme d'
argument marketing mais c'est surtout la
vidéo avec un très gros focus sur la
stabilisation et ça pour moi c'est très
cool que ce soit à l'arrière mais
également à l'avant on a 3 capteur à
l'arrière on va voir un premier de 40 8
mégapixels c'est la fameuse sony mx 5
186 touvre af 1.7 qui a une
stabilisation optique mais également
électronique on va voir un ultra
grand-angle de 12 mégapixels
c'est là sony et mick 508 que bref 2.2
qu'une stabilisation électronique
il ya surtout un champ de vision de 120
degrés en plus peut faire de la macro
avec et puis vous avez un téléobjectif
un tel objectif de 13 mégapixels qui
ouvre à f 2.4 stabilisation électronique
vous avez un zoom optique x 2 1 ou
l'hybride x 5 et un zoom numérique x 20
tandis qu'à l'avant vous avez une caméra
de sa fille de 30 2 mégapixels c'est la
sony et 1516 touvre f 2.4 avec une
stabilisation électronique et si vous
avez un petit laser parce que oui vous
n'êtes pas d'autofocus laser qui vous
servira notamment pour les modes
portrait ça c'est bien ici vous pouvez
filmer jusqu en 4k à 30 images par
seconde en 1080p jusqu'à 60 images par
seconde
vous avez des ralentis en 720p à 240
images par seconde alors en 1080p à 120
images par seconde mais surtout c'était
la promesse faite par au pôle est sud
c'est une super stabilisation pour
toutes nos vidéos avec le mode vidéo
ultra stable 3.0 que vous avez au niveau
de votre caméra grand angle de votre
ultra-grand-angle ou encore la caméra de
celle filles là je teste le mode ultra
stabilité et le truc assez
impressionnant alors moi qui tremble
habituellement la voyez je tiens à une
main et ça ne bouge
absolument pas je peux faire des
mouvements direct m6 on avoir un quota
pour retarder son écran ça c'est dieu la
stabilisation électronique donc ça meurt
calcule tout
c'est vraiment extrêmement le fond on
peut marcher comme ça le truc est
vraiment hypra il pourra impressionnant
ça marche super bien et c'est vrai que
ce mode là il vraiment bien et je vais
essayer maintenant mais sans la
stabilisation des lâchers en mode vidéo
et j'ai désactivé la stabilisation c'est
pas du tout la même
ça bouge beaucoup plus on a les
mouvements de la main même si c'est
quand même corriger c'est quand même
beaucoup moins smooth je reviens en mode
ultra stabiliser sa marche bien et
j'avais un mode professionnel
regardez tout le monde ça là je suis en
stabilité optimum optimale pro le truc
est vraiment très impressionnant tu vois
des petits travelling décaler légèrement
ça ne bouge pas c'est vraiment hyper
hyper bluffant alors que la caméra celle
ci ça marche mais attendent à ce que je
reproche de la caméra de celle ci c'est
que en fait elle est placée juste en bas
la caméra qui fait que j'ai obligé de
l'incliner un peu par les eaux alors là
vous ne voyez pas parce que j'ai le
match mais sinon je me filme les trous
du nez et gagner comme ça là avec ces
matériaux
donc voilà ça c'est un peu le truc un
peu négatif je l'aurais vu plus au
centre ou en eau et si je prends mon
téléphone de l'autre côté ça veut dire
que j'ai la caméra de celle fille dans
mes doigts oui c'est ce que d'avoir un
bout de doigt qui a par exemple sont et
ça fonctionne pas donc ça c'est un peu
dommage et c'est un peu le point de
regret que j'ai là dessus mais par
contre à la stabilité est vachement bien
ou alors si le site calandre de filmer à
la verticale aussi comme ça on note
celle ci j'ai une super stable et ça je
trouve ça vraiment extrêmement bluffant
n'y a pas beaucoup de facteurs de
smartphones qui font déstabilisation
aussi bonne en électronique comme ça
avec les caméras telle fille donc c'est
vraiment bien qu on a aussi un mode
vidéo de nuit alors la stabilité
forcément voyez on va perdre un petit
peu je suis arrêté de bouger mais c'est
vraiment notre quai dédié faut venir
complètement optimisé les scènes pour la
nuit
voilà donc les photos que j'ai pu
prendre avec elle au port et nos quatre
pros de plein jour vous le voyez le
résultat est très correct on n'a pas des
images qui sont sur saturer la qualité
et bien moi ça me va et je trouve que
c'est vraiment très très très honnête on
passe à ultra grand-angle alors l'ultra
grand temps qu on a aucune stabilisation
optique mais ça se voit alors c'est de
mon fait à cause de mon tremblements on
ait une différence de colorimétrie entre
l'ultra l'entendent et le capteur
principal ça c'est normal on passe en x
2 le résultat est correct alors en x 2
ici également aucune stabilisation
optique en x 5 en une stabilisation
électronique qui prend le relais et qui
fait bien le taf et en x 20 voilà vous
voyez il faut oublier caméra principale
c'est vraiment bien les couleurs sont
juste très très bonne gestion de la
plage dynamique on voit bien aussi bien
les petits buissons un petit peu sombre
ici que ce qu'on va retrouver en plein
soleil donc ça marche bien et je suis
très très très satisfait de cette partie
là
ultra grand-angle ira bien aussi sur de
l'extérieur le x 2 est ok le x 5
commence à lisser quand même mais malgré
tout ça reste exploitable et une fois de
plus je vous le dis le x 20 ans l'oubli
caméra principale pas mal on voit gagner
c'est la différence de couleur entre la
caméra principale et hop là
ultra-grand-angle ça se voit c'est très
clair ici deux fois simple ça fait le
taff wavin on oublie on passe sur la
macro alors la macro écoutez moi c'est
pas un truc qui m'enthousiasme trop une
fois de plus mais je trouve que le
boulot est fait et il est fait plutôt
pas mal donc je veux pas critiquer que
l'on soit sur cette photo où sur seule
la safra le tough la caméra de celle
fille fait le boulot
masqué ou pas masquer soleil ou pas
soleil c'est correct sans être
complètement dingue alors la photo nue
ça c'est intéressant
la gelée posé sur un trépied on est sur
une expo longue
voilà ce que vous voyez ici là ces
espèces de lumière c'est une voiture qui
est passé j'ai fait une autre avec une
expo longue ici pour voir que le
téléphone ne bouge absolument pas c'est
pas complètement dingue mais malgré tout
malgré tout ça fait le boulot
lorsque vous le tenez à la main alors on
n'est pas tout à fait dans la même
couleur on est plus sur le jaune voyez
ça change un petit peu le rendu est
assez correcte pouvoir qu'on en pleine
nuit et belle fête plus au pot maîtrise
vraiment bien ces photos de nuit sur le
capteur principal sur l'ultra grand
angle c'est pas terrible un vêtement vos
billets en x 2 on peut hein mais c'est
un peu poussif et c'est pas
extraordinaire et dès qu'on se rapproche
beaucoup trop salie c'est pas terrible
c'est à oublier ici double anneau sim
pas d'extension aux cartes microsd mais
vu que vous avez déjà 250 cigale
intérieur pour moi ce sera largement
suffisant aux peaux nous certifie que
son smartphone et résistant aux
éclaboussures et à la poussière mais par
contre il n'a pas de certification ip68
ski et la certification de base
il nous certifie mais il n'est pas
certifié ça c'est un petit peu dommage
et surtout sur un smartphone à un petit
peu moins de 800 euros ça fait râler les
informations pour le das tout est écrit
là-dessus alors on a un das tête 2 0 892
watts par kilogramme un d'astro de 1,318
watts par kilogramme ayant d'asthme en
de 2,7 107 au watt par kilogramme un
smartphone qui a bien évidemment du nfc
pour vous donner mon avis complet sur ce
smartphone
moi ce que j'aime vraiment retenir ici
c'est le fait de l'avoir de la recharge
extrêmement rapide avec la super boum
2.0 assez bien bien
un bien et bien les techno de au pot
fonctionne très bien sont très maline
vous rechargez extrêmement rapidement et
je suis absolument aucune prise de tête
ça c'est super ce smartphone il peut
destiné pour vous si vous êtes un
créateur souhaite un créatif si vous
faites aussi bien de la photo que de la
vidéo il est extrêmement polyvalent pour
vous dire créer sa chance à très très
bien vous avez l'application solide pour
commencer un peu à vous amuser il ya
plein d'autres applications vous pouvez
venir télécharger après par la suite
pour les plus long terme de créer à
vidéo sur de la photo c'est un
smartphone qui est honnête sur la vidéo
je trouve très bien surtout au niveau de
la stabilisation ça c'est bien et c'est
très bien pensée très bien positionné de
la part de poids parce que autant il ya
beaucoup de smartphones qui sont très
très bons pour la photo tant pour la
vidéo il y en a quelques-uns pas
énormément et que pau vient de se
positionner sur ce créneau là pour moi
je trouve ça vraiment très très malin
donc si vous faites de la vidéo il vous
voulez vous amuser et bien ce smartphone
mais il peut vraiment est fait pour vous
alors attention ici vous aurez
effectivement un tout qui est bien en
vidéo qui est bien stabilisé pour le
tenir à la main et venir ajouté très
rapidement par contre la qualité aux
yeux de vos enregistrements ne va pas
être extraordinaire voyez pour venir
branché ici sur l'usb c'est un petit
micro ou alors en ayant un enregistreur
externe pour avoir une bonne qualité
néanmoins pour l'image pour dupont une
telle chute vous prenez vous filmez vous
êtes vraiment bien ça s'est très très
bien ce que j'aime beaucoup sur ce
smartphone c est la qualité au niveau
multimédia bien évidemment votre écran
qui est d'une très très très bonne
qualité très lumineux super agréable
pour regarder des films des séries pour
venir jouer
il ya suffisamment de performance pour
un smartphone qui est bien qui est
polyvalent et qui il faut de plus et
même si au pot a vraiment mis le focus
sur la partie vidéo sur la 5g et sur la
recharge rapide pourra combler beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de monde parce que il
est quand même très généraliste
maintenant je trouve qu à 799 euros
c'est bien je l'aurais aimé un tout
petit peu moins cher de parler petit
bémol qu'on peut y retrouver notamment
le fait de pas voir sa dragonne 865 moi
j'aime bien je lui recommander si vous
voulez aller chez au point vous faire
plaisir et bien le reno kad pro et très
cool
on se reparle dans quelques jours de
repos avec le renault 4l reno kad z
dites moi vous en tout cas ce que vous
pensez de ce modèle là est ce que le
fait d'abord un focus sur la vidéo pour
vous c'est important et est ce que ce
smartphone pourrait répondre à vos
besoins et à vos attentes si maintenant
il vous fait de l'oeil dites-moi
également pour quelle raison il pour
vous faire un oeil au delà de la partie
vidéo marc et moi tout ça bien
évidemment on bat ans comment
on se trouve extrêmement rapidement
parce que la taxe ne s'arrête jamais
j'en vois beaucoup d'un bon gros bisous
et à très vite
ciao
[Musique]